hi I'm ray I'm a tasty producer today
I've been challenged to take a common
food and make it fancy roads are you
must use the food given you can only up
to the food you can buy whatever
ingredients you wish let's see why it's
today instant mashed potatoes and so you
can probably guess I've never had an
instant mashed potato before according
to the instructions the only thing you
need is hot water and I don't understand
so it's look like powder smell like
butter to make you fancy I have to try
one that it's cooked it looked like
mashed potato it smell like mashed
potato mash potato flavor it's not bad
there is only one texture there is no
crunch so it's everybody it's the same
so we start with this powdered potato
now it's time into mashed potato and I'm
going to transform this mashed potato
into something very fancy
it's a instant mashed potato evolution
okay I've got a great idea
and I'm very excited to make it fancy
okay yeah that's for like a kabocha
squash sage prosciutto garlic onion
pumpkin seeds and chicken stock and from
the pantry olive oil milk utter egg and
flour let's get started make it fancy so
first I'm going to cut about your squash
go just cause it's my favorite kind it's
supposed to be like fall vegetable I
hope you can find at your local grocery
store if you can't go to Asian grocery
market
take out those seeds this is my lady
thank you so much for commenting on
lunchable episode we read who is a lady
and some of them said it by laptop some
of them said I skate everyone has their
own lady and take care we a lady cut
green part because I want to get nice
yellow color and I'm gonna just cut into
like cubes for probably my favorite
season a lot of seasonal vegetable at
the fruit I like kabocha squash
it's almost tastes like butternut squash
ain't butternut squash it's great but
sometimes it's a little bit watery for
me this one's a little bit drier ok so I
go 400 gram of kabocha squash and now
I'm going to onion so I will just need
1/2 onion this one doesn't need to be
precise it's just like dice the reason
you have to take real ladies to spur to
make sharp knife and sharp at the knife
let's see you cry so I now no tears
set this aside I just need two cloves of
garlic
I heard Queen Elizabeth doesn't like
garlic so it's not allowed in the palace
she's not here today so you just have to
mince the garlic and I'm going to start
cooking roll the sage up and slice them
my point it's nice and hot add a little
bit olive oil in onion so you just want
to saute until it's a little bit soft
and translucent you don't want to get
any color only it's nicely cooked and
soft so I'm going to add garlic and sage
you should cook onion three to four
minutes
in garlic about one to two minutes and
then our kabocha squash just slightly
cold it's oil something lightly and you
are 1 cup of chicken stock bring it to a
boil and lower the heat
to medium low heat and then cook this
for 20 minutes or until culture is
completely soft while we're waiting I'm
going to cut more squash so this time we
are cutting into tiny piece transfer to
a baking sheet also for some prosciutto
prosciutto it's very fancy ingredients
this is a quick way of making a dish
fancy next I have pumpkin seeds roasted
pumpkin seed 10 to 15 minutes cubed
squash and prosciutto for 6 minutes in
350 Fahrenheit okay so this looks like
it's cooked through so I'm going to
transfer this cooked butter squash into
a blender
goodbye stink I want to add a little bit
milk so the texture looks good I'm
transferring to a ball so I can cool it
down faster and adding salt this it's
done I'm going to set this aside and
move on to my next step so much for data
time I boil the two cups of water
I mean instant mashed potatoes take off
from the heat Wow it's instant are they
advertised it's like powder - potato do
you think somebody foods thinking I go
mash potato takes so long
how can I make a eastern adding some
mashed potato in the ball I'm going to
call this ok so I have 2x this looks
good
yeah I got my flour and I'm starting
with 1 and 1/2 cup of flour but depends
on the texture you might need more you
might need less we are making dough here
and it shouldn't be too sticky I think
it looks good so I'm going to sprinkle
some flour I'm really happy to make
dough from instant mashed potato it
walks super well so I use bench scraper
to cut the dough but if you don't have
it you can just use a knife this is nice
because it's not sharp so it doesn't
damage the surface I'm shaping this
dough into a long rope shape cut this
just look like a little pillow use this
new key roller so I can make the shape
push in roll it kind of reminds me is it
legally from bent and flat so it's a new
way of attract your love interest
Christian roll
I'm transferring into flour baking sheet
so it doesn't stick together if you
don't have this store you can just use
fork and it makes the reduce if you have
a leftover mashed potato from
Thanksgiving dinner you can definitely
make this dish for next day so these are
looking good so I'm going to boil some
water so I have 5 tbsp butter I'm going
to make brown butter in the way start
bubbling and when you start seeing like
brown bits it's ready it's kind of give
them nutty flavor it complements the
Haas dish but it's bubbling up I'm going
to safely you just want it to crisp up
so I think it's ready
so I'm going to remove from the heat its
water it's boiling so when this is
cooked it's gonna float on the surface
and it's gonna happen very quickly I
don't want to too much because it will
lower the water temperature so those
came up put this in coated I'm gonna do
one more
okay so much - looking good quote it in
the butter so those are looking good we
can freeze this and save it for later
all the components already now I am
moving on to next step so I roasted a
pumpkin seed and called it down I'm
going to process in a food processor you
don't want to make it too fine just like
kind of rough chop and now I'm ready to
play I have kabocha squash puree and I
want to transfer to squeeze bottle I
want to play this very fancy so we have
ton table today put the squeeze photo in
the middle and rotate the play to make
the spiral shape looks cool new key and
off center crispy prosciutto and breaks
up sprinkle diced kabocha squash grinded
pumpkin seed and I have fried sage also
I want to kind of make you stand it up
and we are done
[Music]
tastes like Paul Casey it's delicious
and fancy day Ryan hi
so welcome to evolution of instant
mashed potatoes the evolution of instant
mashed potatoes I thought it was
scallops but it's not it must be me okey
yes alright and mustard and fried basil
and fried like tomato skins
oh so put this into now mm-hmm lovely
Tomatoes scanner basil pancetta
prosciutto prosciutto yeah what's that
yes say you yellow one was it mustard
either starett's on here as well
yeah squash squash oh there's a subset
of squashes under spell squash squash
squash it's not really my specialty
[Music]
Japanese some sort of nuts yeah i nuts
it's not nuts
it feeds pine seeds pumpkin seeds it's
such a fall dish yes make it fancy oh hi
first impressions on the plating is the
fancy Famers mean I say it every time
hmm there are so many flavors going on
here so I made this from instant mashed
potato I feel like I know my own stream
potatoes and this doesn't taste like it
at all
zahana we have one of things to do I
think make it fancy thank you so much
for watching I hope you make it home if
you make it please tag me on instagram
and don't forget the dance make it fancy
[Music]